[Musique]
mec je suis en train de regarder les
plannings dans 15 jours on a le Félix
qui tombe
les pafs
mais par contre on a une mission
expliquer la manière dont notre passion
et notre métier
est devenu finalement notre quotidien le
faire de manière simple sans utiliser
plein de plein de mots compliqués sur ce
qu'on fait et sans vulgariser et du coup
rendre le truc incompréhensible par tout
le monde du coup je me pose une question
de fond lorsque tu expliques ton job à
tes parents comment tu t'y prends
alors j'allais les voir et je leur
disais papa maman je suis à cœur à cœur
éthique et puis première réaction
d'entrée c'était non mais attends Victor
tu es sûr que c'est légal ça c'est
vraiment sûr que c'est légal ce que tu
fais après j'ai essayé de leur expliquer
c'est de faire preuve de pédagogie et
bah je leur raconte un petit peu nos
aventures ça a l'air de les faire
rigoler mais j'avais toujours le temps
tu as vraiment jeté cinq années d'études
pharmaceutique à la poubelle pour
continuer à faire une musique avec mon
ordinateur
donc je sais pas je me dis
qu'il y a un fossé on est en train
d'essayer de combler mais
j'aurais un peu de mal à le faire tout
seul et je ne sais pas qu'est-ce que tu
en penses comment ça se passe pour toi
bah déjà de base vu que je suis plus
vieux que toi je prends un peu de recul
je reviens 10 ans en arrière et je me
dis effectivement à l'époque les sons de
cloche qui résonnent dans ma tête c'est
mais qu'est-ce que tu fous devant
l'écran toute la journée sors de devant
l'écran tu apprends rien ou tu vas te
cramer les yeux ou à défaut sur la
sphère professionnelle il y avait
beaucoup le discours de on est désolé
monsieur mais on a trouvé quelqu'un de
plus compétent pour gérer la sécurité
informatique de notre entreprise désolé
vous avez pas le bout de papier on vous
recrutera pas après par contre d'une
certaine manière il faut comparer avec
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
on a trouvé un métier dans lequel on
peut s'introduire autant dans le
boulanger du coin que dans la
multinationale on est payé pour et c'est
reconnu comme activité légale donc
finalement je me dis bah c'est une belle
revanche sur la vie alors oui mais du
coup pour le télix on pratique
il va falloir faire super attention à
une notion il faut démystifier et
surtout pas faire l'amalgame entre le
hacker et le cybercriminal parce que
tous les infos tu vois quoi un à coeur
le vilain à cœur qui a hacké les
derniers photos de Britney Spears et
c'est pas c'est pas ouf non non
ça va être assez quand même assez
incisif
un petit peu attention à ce qu'on dit et
donc j'ai regardé toutes les vidéos de
la chaîne tous les TEDx qui sont passés
et on a un coach ah j'ai Didier
il me disait des conseils il nous a
accompagné et donc j'ai pas mal réfléchi
je me suis dit
comme ça on décrit bien toute l'histoire
toute la progression et après en
généralise on leur dit bon c'est pas que
l'informatique c'est se dire je sais pas
bah j'apprends
et après on leur dit non mais c'est un
sujet qui est super important c'est un
sujet majeur c'est du partage de la
communication la transmission de jeunes
en trois mots
simples synthétique et concis aussi on a
à peu près une quinzaine de minutes
grand max je te propose l'approche sur
laquelle on va s'appuyer on sort du
cliché à cœur bon ok on vient avec nos
PC et tout on fait un effort on enlève
les suites à capuche ok par contre sur
le reste on utilise des exemples très
visuels on va pouvoir caster en plus du
contenu à l'écran ça ça va être cool et
ces exemples très simples on essaye de
passer le message sur finalement c'est
pas toujours de mecs 24/24 chez eux
derrière un écran en train de bidouiller
et qui finissent dans Mr robot
c'est pas la bonne image du coup premier
cave qui me vient en tête comme ça nos
cartes de visite en métal
on explique comment on est allé voir
avec notre état d'esprit un peu tordus
une entreprise bretonne qui fabrique des
portails de base on leur a dit bonjour
on voudrait 1000 cartes de visite en
métal ça va nous coûter très cher on le
sait mais on veut juste voir vous voir
jouer avec la dernière découpeuse plasma
et dans quel but parce que c'est trop
cool les gens à qui on va la donner ils
vont sonner au portique à l'aéroport
c'est déjà pas mal et en plus ils vont
pouvoir décrocher de la carte de visite
de quoi crocheter des serrures
et je pousse le vis encore plus loin
pour le fun de manière totalement
aléatoire on les scotch dans la salle du
télix sous les tables on passe en avant
dernier et personne s'en est rendu
compte c'est pas mal ça alors l'idée
elle est super cool vraiment moi ça me
botte
par contre
distribuer du matériel de prostage et en
plus afficher une image qui en fait la
promotion
en termes d'image c'est peut-être pas
dingue je ne suis pas trop là dessus au
pire on monte pas la photo non non non
non
par contre la volonté de matérialiser et
dire on n'est pas tout le temps derrière
nos PC ça peut être pas mal et ça me
fait penser à un truc on était en
intrusion physique pour un client
récemment est venir chez lui qu'est-ce
que tu as fait toi tu es allé crocheter
direct le coffre-fort et moi on m'a
déguisé en agent de sécurité on s'est
baladé sur le site à peu près toute la
journée à manger ils ont payé à manger
et on sait pas faire attraper elle t'a
pris des selfies sur le toit ouais
c'était sympa ça
moi je suis chaud parce qu'effectivement
en plus c'est sur le terrain on montre
qu'on sort de chez nous et tout mais ça
peut être cool pour passer le message
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement les
entreprises elles font appel à des
hackers il y a tout le cadre
réglementaire qui va autour dans quel
but c'est réalisé c'est de montrer ce
qui va pas les aider à corriger top par
contre il y a quand même une vigilance
c'est qu'on si on s'y prend mal
finalement on risque de subir l'amalgame
de bah c'est peut-être illégal ce qu'ils
font donc faut qu'on soit super prudent
on en parle mais on n'a pas la photo OK
alors par contre tout ça ça reste quand
même très opérationnel est lié à ce
qu'on fait dans notre métier au
quotidien tous les jours mais il faut
qu'on prenne du recul parce que c'est
vrai qu'on parle du hacking tu parlais
de l'historique tout à l'heure etc mais
il y a un truc qui manque c'est l'état
d'esprit du hacker
tu sais l'état d'esprit du hacker c'est
finalement pas que l'informatique et du
coup j'ai un exemple qui me vient en
tête parce que mon système d'alarme pour
des raisons droit on pourra pas le
diffuser ça va pas ça va pas passer mais
par contre c'est le meuble que j'ai
acheté c'est que j'ai découpé j'ai mis
des chatières et j'ai connecté la
litière des chats dans le meuble pour
recevoir les alertes sur le téléphone
quand j'oublie de faire mes tâches
ménagères à la maison ça c'est un bon
exemple tu vas pas trop d'électronique
et puis si finalement du bricolage de la
bidouille dans le but de résoudre un
problème quand on est feignant exemple
appliqué super par contre tu nous vois
assis sur un canapé et au dessus de nos
têtes on met l'image d'une litière comme
ça
par contre
le fait de concrétiser c'est une super
idée je pense que la façon la plus
marquante de concrétiser c'est sur
l'organisation du tennis on fait pas un
stand-up on prend un canap on se pose
tous les deux on prend les PC ça tombe
bien en plus on n'a pas besoin de
réviser on a tout sur les écrans on peut
lire et puis tu peux on leur dit que
c'est comme ça que on approche les
choses différemment moi je te suis ok
bah écoute je te propose un truc
j'appelle l'orga et puis on voit ça
passe ça roule
bon un TEDx sur un canapé sérieusement
je sais pas si certains d'entre vous
s'attendaient à ce genre de format et je
vous avoue que nous non plus on
s'attendait pas mais c'est pas grave on
s'est dit il faut y aller fonce et puis
bon si on se plante c'est pas grave mais
au moins la tenter
et puis on est venu parler de hacking il
fallait quand même qu'on vienne avec
quelque chose dans tout petit peu plus
croustillant et on avait préparé aussi
d'autres formats de de
conférences on a voulu partager d'autres
choses mais c'était un petit peu plus
ennuyeux alors franchement ça nous
chauffait un peu moins
ce qui vient de se passer la justice
c'est un exemple idéal pour nous c'est
la meilleure manière d'illustrer comment
au quotidien avec Victor lorsqu'on
regarde le monde autour de nous on
croise tous les événements avec les
interactions qu'on a comment on essaye
finalement de changer la vision
traditionnelle qu'on attend de nous ça
fait des années qu'on s'entraîne à
essayer de faire les choses différemment
pour quelle raison finalement parce que
c'est amusant d'une part c'est légal
aussi il faut pas l'oublier et puis
surtout ce qui arrive des fois c'est que
c'est surprenant et à travers toutes ces
toutes ces approches finalement il y a
une passion qui ressort et cette passion
c'est celle qui a amené le changement le
plus radical dans notre vie celle de
passer le statut de chômeur à suite
salarié mais en prenant du recul c'est
aussi faire d'une passion de toujours un
métier de tous les jours
et qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve dans cette passion qu'est-ce
qu'on retrouve c'est la volonté de
pirater c'est ça en fait notre
savoir-faire premier en tant que
akurétique c'est on est capable de
pirater tout ce qui contient une
composante électronique tout ce qui
passe entre nos mains c'est notre
plaisir mais sans sauter sur des
exemples extrêmement précis celui de la
vieille voiture que l'on avait qu'on
était étudiant à la caméra qui peut y
avoir au fond de la salle ça serait
manqué de recul et quand on prend un
petit peu de recul qu'est-ce qu'on
aperçoit on aperçoit que elle a capacité
première du hacker c'est celle
d'apprendre toute sa vie et comment
est-ce qu'on a appris vient un outil
très simple merveilleux et infini qui
s'appelle Internet
lorsqu'on pose la question à des curieux
des bidouilleurs ou à des hackers
définis moi Internet
le hacker va vous répondre qu'en fait
internet c'est un terrain de jeu une
zone de créativité d'innovation dans
laquelle il est possible de faire tout
ce qu'on veut pour quelle raison il y a
pas de frontière c'est un univers certes
virtuel mais en quelques millisecondes
en quelques clips on est à l'autre bout
de la planète donc finalement c'est le
plus grand c'est le plus grand magasin
de jouets au monde
et dans ce magasin de jouets qu'est-ce
que les hackers aiment faire finalement
c'est
créer détourner tous l'écosystème qui
vit dans le but de faire ce qu'on attend
pas deux mais ça ne s'arrête pas là ça
va beaucoup plus loin l'état d'esprit du
hacker l'état d'esprit du hacker je l'ai
découvert quand j'étais enfant avec la
boîte de Lego qu'on soit à Noël on
l'ouvre il y a 1000 briques dedans on
prend le manuel et du coup on attend de
nous qu'on fabrique une voiture rouge
on le jette à la poubelle et après avec
on fait un lave-vaisselle
j'ai fait ce que je voulais j'ai utilisé
mon imagination j'ai utilisé ma
créativité c'est aussi les parents qui
se rendent dans un magasin d'une fameuse
marque suédoise qui fait des meubles en
kit pas trop trop cher c'est génial
quand on est étudiant on va acheter deux
tabourets à 10 euros la forme des
tabourets en elle-même est idéale on
l'ouvre on jette le manuel à la poubelle
et avec on fait une luge pour quelle
raison payer trois fois moins cher que
si on allait l'acheter directement dans
le magasin à côté mais dans le but de
partager un moment un moment de
bricolage un moment de passion avec ses
enfants et finalement c'est ça l'état
d'esprit du hacker appliqué à des
exemples de la vie quotidienne et quel
est le point commun que l'on retrouve
dans tous ces exemples dans toutes ces
approches c'est la liberté
la liberté de penser la liberté de se
réapproprier le monde mais surtout la
liberté de ne pas faire ce qui est
attendu de nous ou parfois même de faire
ce que vous vous attendez de vous-même
et cette liberté c'est tant bien qui est
si précieux il faut la protéger je me
rappelle au collège Madame Michu me
disait en cinquième ta liberté s'arrête
là où commence celle des autres alors
petit est impertinent que j'étais je ne
comprenais pas forcément mais avec les
années
je me suis aperçu que c'était un conseil
assez avisé quand on souhaite éviter la
perquisition à 6h du matin avec les
hommes en bleu qui toque à votre porte
mais cette notion d'illégalité de
criminalité elle est beaucoup trop
souvent
perçue quand on pense aux mots hacking
pourquoi parce que on ouvre les médias
on ouvre la presse et qu'est-ce que l'on
entend on parle du hacker du vilain à
coeur du très méchant à cœur mais ça
n'est pas ça le hacking le hacking c'est
l'application de cette liberté
l'application de ses concepts à la vie
quotidienne pour débloquer un autre
regard sur pour débloquer un regard que
l'on qualifie en dehors de la boîte
à travers tout ce qu'on vient de faire
là on avait un objectif premier partagé
le mantra dans le domaine du hacking
depuis les années 60 même si il a fallu
couper Victor lorsqu'il avait tenté de
l'expliquer c'est sharing is Karine
partagez
et Karine c'est prendre soin
dans quel but on le fait pour le plaisir
parce que c'est fun mais surtout
orange c'est attiser votre curiosité
d'une part et vous donner envie de
découvrir un monde qui du prime abord
peut sembler mystique nébuleux
aujourd'hui une fois de plus
et on a posé les fondamentaux théoriques
mais quoi de mieux que la pratique
finalement donc on a un deal à vous
proposer à vous tous qui est assis sur
ces sièges aujourd'hui pardon à vous
tous qui nous regarderaient peut-être
demain sur Internet une fameuse
plateforme avec un rectangle rouge et un
triangle blanc que beaucoup connaissent
on arrête la conférence là on met sur
pause sur Internet on revient tout au
début de ce qui vient de se passer
nous deux protagonistes sur cette scène
vous nous oubliez totalement et vous
devenez observateur curieux vous changez
votre vision sur ces 15 minutes qui
viennent de se dérouler vous aurez
peut-être le plaisir de découvrir des
choses qui ont été dissimulées en plus
de celles qui sont sous vos tables
merci
[Applaudissements]